flight time in horizontal range these
are kind of pet again what flight time
feed dealers what is the total amount of
time that the object is actually flight
is in the air ok so again come back to
your six equations of motion which looks
like it will be loose natural choice to
solve for flat time I'm here right this
is the end point right so x 0 time
whatever it happens to be at that moment
just like I said upper here what's
happening right down here the vertical
displacement is 0 I'm back on the ground
right yeah so I'm going to say it hits
the ground when one equals 0 came back
to that right because flight time is
defined by how long I via the air and
now I'm no longer in the air cuz y
equals zero I can go ahead I can solve
this equation minus 5t squared plus 15 2
equals 0 what would you like me to do ok
i can divide through by i could buy
through by negative 5 that'll be nice on
now what I'm going to factorize and I
have two solutions to this why do I have
two solutions because I began at at time
0 I was on the ground and that's what
this equation was solving here right so
therefore i can say for the particular
question i'm answering i want when it
hits the ground that's the flight time
rank so i can take but i want some
positive time I am NOT interested in the
actual start time so therefore it's
after three seconds only ok that make
sense so that answers the question of
flight time by the way you should be a
little suspicious when you look at
flight time versus when you get to the
height of the motion right that should
make you slightly suspicious if I know
the flight time which is three seconds
how am I going to use that to answer the
compile depression okay so horizontal
range is how far away that thing lands
from me right install all lit up care no
interest in that anymore I've worked out
how long it's going to take to get to
the end so I'm going to pop that into
horizontal displacement here right
that's just going to take your life
therefore X is equal to 15 root 3 times
3 is 45 33 okay so you can see here
again remember I said that equations are
easy it's working out which equations
you need to use and what you need to let
them be equal to alright last question
we got here is great we know how hey
where will you how long it took to get
to where it's going to get to the end
this last question is well what's it
doing when it arrives impact speed okay
so just like before we do our starting
things over here ok we're going to draw
another diagram but this time we're
going to draw the moment of impact ok so
therefore if I drawing box here the mode
of impact I'm coming from the air and
I'm healing the ground ok so therefore
i'm not going to start from the bottom
left corner here and then project
upwards instead I'm somewhere in the air
and I'll find downwards and a few ground
so impact speed and angle how we're
going to work these things out on the
diagram what I'm working on is this this
is my impact speed where is impact angle
on this diagram
it's it's another angle of inclination
is it except it's just facing in the
opposite direction okay oh because we
are measuring from the ground you never
worry about this angle here from the
vertical it's always this angle of
inclination okay all right this is the
opposite of what we're doing before
right I knew what the angle and speed
were when i started and then i worked
out x dot and why not so how am I going
to work out this now if I don't have
yeah okay so if I know the time when i'm
hitting which i do then i can work out
why dot and in the same way i could also
work out it's not only both of those
different okay yeah say oh thanks not
yes very good but I still need to know
what it is ok so I'm going to say at T
equals 3 reminds will say because we
could just state it right it's
horizontal velocity is constant so it's
just going to be 53 why dad has been
changing right all the way through so
when I put in time equals 3 here's my
wide don't equation here this is minus
sorry 30-30 plus 15 which is minus 15
yeah so therefore I've got this here and
of course it has to be negative because
at this instant in time I am dropping
right I'm going in this direction ok so
now I know what each of these numbers is
from there I can work out my thinner and
I can work out my me now interestingly
when you compare this diagram with that
diagram they're congruent to each other
are they all the dimensions are the same
but what's different is I've been
flipped over I've been reflected
horizontally I'm coming down rather than
going on ok but because it leaks kagura
that means I know what this is right you
see that I could use Pythagoras again
but we've already worked this thing out
ok so therefore V equals
mm what about the angle it's also called
online so third 90 degrees is my angle
of impact so you can see there's this
huge amount of symmetry remember I said
hey that's suspicious isn't it right
your flight time is exactly double the
time it takes to get to the vertex of
motion right the hydrogen and in the
same way the way you began sorry I here
did the way you begin is how you end it
if it's a perfectly symmetrical
situation if I fired from the ground and
if I landed on the ground does that make
sense now let me just change the
question slightly and leave this for you
as something to have a go at what if you
were firing and you hit a platform what
if there's like a raised platform okay
let's see how high do we get 1,100
suppose this platform was 5 meters tall
okay let me ask the question again I
looking to answer here but I'm gonna let
you try work it out what would I do to
work out the impact speed and angular
that are now different they're gonna be
different right something different is
going on how would you go about finding
these two if i change this thing about
the final part of the question right I
could ask all of these I could ask what
will be your new flight time and
horizontal range if you're going to hit
this 5 metre platform and what will be
your impacts being an angle now you're
here this raised the rather than coming
back down to the ground okay